emergency medical services station 18
the Bronx at the peak of the kovat 19
pandemic one of the busiest call centers
in New York City ambulance crews saw
their daily call volume more than double
and a number of cardiac arrests
skyrocket along with their stress levels
Anthony Alma Shara recalls responding to
13 cardiac arrests over the course of a
16-hour double shift your going into the
fray doing all your protocols and
everything you can into meeting people
you think you should be able to get him
back and you're not wait this person was
just talking to me why can't why are
they dying Alma Jairus says the strain
has taken a toll on him and his
colleagues most of whom have much less
than his 17 years of experience the
average age of a New York EMT just 25
it's a very young workforce with very
low experience and that's dangerous
threatens lives the Union argues that
low pay and high stress have led to high
turnover and a less experienced
workforce the people of the city of
literally dying because of the lack of
experience and the retention problem
that EMS has EMTs are a part of the New
York City Fire Department but they don't
receive similar pay or benefits to other
first responders in fact they make tens
of thousands of dollars a year less than
firefighters police officers and
sanitation workers with similar levels
of experience while the mayor has
heralded the work of EMTs and called for
federal assistance to help frontline
workers 200 billion dollars nationally
to establish hazard pay for essential
workers and their survivors the city
does not formally recognize the empties
as a uniformed emergency service they've
been working without a contract for more
than a year we go into dangerous
situations all day long shooting
stabbings what have you and now we're
going into situations where we still
respond to all those calls and everybody
is a potential Cova patient so it's it's
fighting a war against an invisible
bullet he worries that strain has and
will continue to cost law
in the department as well as the
community it serves
Christon salumi al jazeera New York